2019 stürzte im Kongo eine Anton auf der
wagner-gruppe AB auf ihrer
Passagierliste befand sich auch hier
geniperion seine Mitarbeiter hatten
jeglichen Kontakt zu ihm verloren erst
Tage später stellte sich heraus dass das
Söldner Boss putz munter war da er die
Maschine gar nicht bestiegen hatte das
war vor vier Jahren damals hat ihn sein
Herr und Meister noch gebraucht doch ein
zweites Mal sollte ihn der Koch nicht
mehr so leicht von der Schippe springen
der Chef der wagnergruppe ist
hingerichtet worden alles deutet darauf
hin dass du mir Putin endlich seine
Rache bekommen hat dies geschah genau
zwei Monate nach dem Russlands
berühmteste Söldnergruppe einen Aufstand
inszenierte und auf Moskau marschierte
um das Desaster in der Ukraine
anzuprangern nun das alles ist jetzt
Geschichte das Verkehrsflugzeug mit der
Registrierungsnummer Romeo Alpha 02795
dass der wagnergruppe gehört stürzt am
Mittwoch den 23 August 20 24 in der
Region quer ab nachdem ist von Moskau in
Richtung St Petersburg gestartet war das
was sie auf dem Bildschirm seht ist der
abstürzende Business-Jet breakins aber
was genau hat den Crash dieses
Flugzeuges verursacht nun die Wahrheit
ist dass der Flieger sowohl nach Angaben
aus dem Umfeld der wagnergruppe als auch
aus westlichen Geheimdienstquellen von
niemand anderem als der russischen
Flugabwehr höchstpersönlich abgeschossen
worden sein könnte zum Zeitpunkt der
Aufnahme dieses Videos war noch nicht
geklärt ob es sich nicht auch um eine
Bombe gehandelt haben könnte allerdings
ist dies nicht wirklich ausschlaggebend
gemäß offizieller Angaben waren Wagner
Bossi und seine rechte Hand der
militärische Leiter der Organisation
Wagner Kommandant
ihre Leichen wurden auch schon bereits
von Wagner Angehörigen identifiziert mit
anderen Worten wir haben es hier mit
einer klaren Hinrichtung zu tun alles
deutet darauf wenn das der Kreml
beschloss sie stilvoll zu erledigen aber
erst nachdem er sich vergewissert hatte
das wirklich beide Schwergewichte
deshalb in der Gruppe sich sicher genug
fühlten um leichtfertig zusammen
in genau derselben Maschine zu reisen
scheinbar hielt ist Putin für zu
gefährlich den zweiköpfigen Wagner
Drachen nur einen Kopf abzuschlagen
meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
wenn wir auf das bewegte Leben Jewgeni
brekordhin zurückschauen können wir mit
Fug und Recht behaupten dass er das
Ebenbild der russischen Politik der
letzten Jahrzehnte war vom
Würstchenverkäufer in den frühen 1990er
Jahren und späteren Betreiber eines
etwas feineren Restaurants dank den er
übrigens eine Verbindung mit dem
russischen Präsidenten herstellte wurde
diese Restaurant Tycoon schließlich zum
Warlord er leitete das wohl wichtigste
und bekannteste seltene Unternehmen der
Welt mit Geschäften in Russland Afrika
und dem Nahen Osten und vielen anderen
Teilen der Welt wurde schon sogar zu
einem der sichtbarsten Gesichter
Russlands brutaler Invasion in der
Ukraine er war sozusagen die
bestmögliche leibhaftige Verkörperung
des russischen Mafia Kapitalismus doch
nun ist seine Geschichte zu Ende
gegangen natürlich gibt es noch viele
Dinge die wir nicht wissen und
vielleicht nie wissen werden aber
andererseits gibt es auch Dinge deren
wir uns schon jetzt sicher sein können
also was genau ist passiert warum hat
sich Wladimir Putin zur Doppel
dkapitation der wagnertruppe
entschlossen und vor allem warum hat er
beschlossen es gerade jetzt zu tun wieso
hat er nicht schon viel früher
ausschalten lassen und eine weitere
nicht unwichtige Frage welche Folgen
wird dieser Schritt haben in diesem
Video werden wir all diese Fragen
beantworten lasst uns also sofort
loslegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn eines in dieser ganzen
Angelegenheit klar ist dann das Putins
Hand noch nie gezittert hat wenn es
darum ging seine Gegner zu verfolgen und
auszuschalten das hat er meist auf die
schrecklichste Art und Weise getan so
wurde der flüchtige russische Spion
Alexander ledwinenko in einer Londoner
hotelkantine mit radioaktiven Polonium
vergiftet der Oppositionspolitiker war
das ihrem soft wurde in der Nähe des
roten Platzes erschossen und die
Journalistin ja wurde in ihrem eigenen
Haus hingerichtet diese nur drei
Beispiele für eine elend lange Liste von
Menschen die in Russland vergiftet
erschossen oder einfach aus dem Fenster
eines Hochhauses geworfen wurden
[Musik]
auf dieser Liste stehen so bekannte
Namen wie die des Oppositionsführers
Alex
ehemaliger doppelspion der in
Großbritannien lebt diese zwei Männer
haben brutale gibt Anschläge übrigens
nur sehr knapp überlebt wir haben über
Putins Morde und die historisch Uhr
russische Tradition der Ermordung
politischer Gegner sogar mal ein ganzes
eigenes Video gedreht ich werde es euch
verlinken falls euch dieses auch
langfristig wichtige Thema interessiert
denn die Wahrheit ist dass die vom
russischen Präsidenten geförderten
Exekutionen in vielen Fällen nicht nur
darauf abzielen eine bestimmte Person zu
eliminieren sondern auch den Rest der
potenziellen Gegner mit den
größtmöglichen
aber Vorsicht denn auch wenn es sich um
eine Konstante in der gesamten Ära Putin
handelt hat der Krieg in der Ukraine ein
Vorher und Nachher markiert dieser
stellt eindeutig einen Wendepunkt dar
[Musik]
handelt es sich bei den meisten Opfern
bisher um Putins offizielle Gegner
Menschen die seine Regierung offen
kritisiert oder den Augen Moskau aus
Russland verraten haben hat sich der
Kreis seine Opfer wesentlich ausgeweitet
seit Putin die russische Armee in die
Ukraine geschickt hat während der
letzten Monate sind mehrere Menschen ums
Leben gekommen die zu dem Gehörten was
man als Russland Wirtschaft Elite
bezeichnen kann Mitglieder des Systems
die vielleicht nicht ganz loyal waren
oder die wenig Begeisterung für den
Krieg zeigten wir sprechen hier von
Führungskräften die in einigen Fällen
ihr Leben und ihre Familien sowohl in
Russland als auch außerhalb Russland
verloren haben es gibt sogar eine
seltsame Geschichte wie diese hier in
Deutschland
ein Putin Kritiker stürzte von einem
Gebäude in Washington war es wirklich
ein Selbstmord tja das ist schon eine
gewagter Schritt denn es bedeutet dass
man nicht einmal mehr sicher ist selbst
wenn man zum direkten regierungsumfeld
gehört und jetzt war eben der nächste
unbequeme an der Reihe
dies ist ein Foto des Hauptquartiers der
wagnergruppe in St Petersburg kurz
nachdem der Tod ihres Anführers bekannt
geworden war der Anführer der
wagnergruppe hält Russlands ein wahrer
Patriot seines Vaterlandes jetzt
genehmigtaschen von Verrätern an
Russland es sollte niemanden überraschen
der katastrophale Krieg in der Ukraine
dazu geführt dass eine privat Armee auf
Moskau marschiert ist und jetzt scheinen
die Konsequenzen eben eingetreten zu
sein US-Präsidenten selbst hat es sehr
klar ausgedrückt
klar im Grunde handelt es sich um keine
große Überraschung irgendwie haben alle
mit einem baldigen Ableben bringen es
war nur eine Frage der Zeit bis er nicht
mehr genügend Trümpfe in der Hand hier
mit denen er seine Exitus noch
hinauszögern konnte nur zwei Tage zuvor
hatte das US-Außenministerium seine
Bürger zum ersten Mal aufgefordert weiß
Russland sofort zu verlassen ein Zufall
oder hatten die USA Informationen und
fürchteten die Konsequenzen die Tausende
von den Belarus befind gewissen Partner
sollte man aus der Ermordung ihrer
Anführer ziehen würden fakt ist dass der
weißrussische Präsident
lukaschenmaschine die Mobilfunkmasten in
der Region in der Wagner in Belarus
campiert abschalten ließ um die Söldner
von der Kommunikation abzuschneiden das
Wagner kämpfert aufgelöst die Söldner
kehren nach Russland zurück und werden
dort Verträge mit der Armee
unterzeichnen um sie leichter in der
Ukraine verheizen zu können dabei hatten
viele Wagner Kommandeure die armea
gerade aufgrund der dortigen Zustände
verlassen und sie werden wohl wieder
hoch motiviert sein noch wird
Verteidigungsminister scheuburg die
alten Kommandostrukturen und
Kameradschaften Wagners in seine Armee
dulden zu groß wäre die Gefahr von
Verschwörungen ach ja und noch etwas
folgendes war am 13 August 19 Tage vor
der Hinrichtung veröffentlicht worden
Experte der Anführer der russischen
wagnergruppe wird innerhalb von sechs
Monaten von Putin ermordet werden oder
einen weiteren Putsch anführen Putin
nannte brigochen im Fernsehen einen
Vertreter jeder weiß was sie mit
Verrätern machen und Putin hat es nicht
getan aber er will ihn tot sehen okay
Putin wollte ihn aus dem Verkehr ziehen
daran gab es wenig Zweifel und nun hat
es sich bestätigt
vergesst nicht das trikotin genau zwei
Monate vor dem Abschluss des Flugzeugs
eine Meuterei gegen die kreml-führung
anführte eine Meuterei bei der er so
weit ging auf Moskau zu marschieren bei
der seine Privatarmee mehrere russische
Flugzeuge abschossen und bei der der
wagengeschäft zu allen Überfluss auch
noch den Krieg in der Ukraine des
kreditierte das gesamte kremlar aktiv in
einer eindrucksvollen Videobotschaft
zerschmetterten
Ideen
für
brace 17 wurde der Aufstand schließlich
durch einen Deal beendet den der
weißrussische Präsident Alexander
lukaschenke ausgehandelt hatte die
wagnerführung erklärte sich bereit die
Meuterei zu beenden und erhielt im
Gegenzug Begnadigungen die Möglichkeit
ihre Geschäfte weiterzuführen und einen
sicheren Hafen in Weißrussland
ich garantiere dir und deinen Leuten
absolute Sicherheit Alexander
Lukaschenka am
24.06.2023 und jetzt sieht die ganze
Welt mal wieder bestätigt wie viel das
Wort Liebe putinstar tatsächlich wert
ist ich meine alle die zumindest über
einen winzigen Funken Verstand verfügen
wussten schon seit einiger Zeit vertraue
niemals Wladimir Putin egal was er
verspricht welchen Deal er mit dir
abschließt welchen Vertrag er
unterzeichnet nichts davon ist nur einen
einzigen pfifferlingwert das viele Putin
selbst ist auch noch stolz auf seine
psychopathische Falschheit und
kaltblütige Hinterhältigkeit ein Mann
der kurz nach dem Abschluss seine enorme
Genugtuung nicht im geringsten verbaggt
auf dem Bild das ihr gerade seht wusste
der russische Diktator bereits das
Wagners Flugzeug abgeschossen worden war
erzählt mir nicht dass er nicht
glücklich aussieht wie ein
Honigkuchenpferd tja seine Rache Plan
war wie am Schnürchen aufgegangen die
Säuberung war praktisch abgeschlossen in
einer Fernsehansprache am am nächsten
Tag bezeichnete Putin bregorian trocken
als einen begabten Menschen mit einem
schweren Schicksal sprach sein
Angehörigen sein Beileid aus und
versprach die Untersuchung des
Flugzeugabsturzes zu Ende zu bringen
Business es usual gut gehen ist der
ultimative Rache Apostel wenn ich bringe
euch in wäre würde ich meinen Vorkoster
nicht entlassen William burns CIA
Direktor bemerkenswert ist auch das
Putin in seinem Statement keinerlei Wort
darüber verlor das mit pregorians Tod
auch Russland einen wichtigen Mann
verloren hätte die Message war klar
dieser Moor hatte seine Schuldigkeit
getan er konnte gehen und wir reden hier
nicht nur über Wagner
am Mittwoch dem 23 August wenige Stunden
vor dem Abschluss des Flugzeugs
bestätigte russische nachrichtenagenture
die die offizielle Entlassung von Sergej
surrovic gehen auch bekannt als General
armagedorn es handelte sich um eines der
Schwergewichte der russischen
Streitkräfte den Chef der Luftwaffe oder
der raumfahrtkräfte eine der fähigsten
Befehlshaber der Invasion in der Ukraine
der Grund für die Entlassung nun der
Verdacht dass er enge Verbindungen zu
kriegen hatte tatsächlich bereits kurz
nach dem Wagner Aufstand verhaftet
worden die Frage ist war er die
Schwachstelle die am 23 und 24 Juni
versagte nun das werden wir vielleicht
nie erfahren aber eines ist klar Putin
hat einen mutigen Schritt getan und ja
wir konnten uns alle vorstellen dass der
russische Präsident früher oder später
versuchen würde sich zu rächen aber
warum wählte er eine solche Form der
Hinrichtung und gerade jetzt was hatte
der russische Präsident davon hätte er
gregorie nicht einfach bei seiner
Audienz im Travel verhaften und vor
Gericht stellen können wie z.bigin was
ist die Message und was sind die Folgen
dieser theatralischen Hinrichtung und
das alles nehmen wir jetzt genau unter
die Lupe aufgepasst
der optimale Zeitpunkt
meine Lieben Zuschauer Wagner war dem
russischen Präsidenten lästig geworden
Putin musste die Truppe aus dem Weg
räumen warum nun erstens weil die
Tatsache das Gregorian immer noch in
Russland herumlief eine echte Blamage
für Putin war und ein klares Zeichen von
Schwäche der Wagen der Chef hatte ihn
mit seinem Arsch auf Moskau von ganz
Russland und der ganzen Welt
herausgefordert und gedemütigt natürlich
kann es sich ein Diktator nicht leisten
ein solches Verhalten zu tolerieren wenn
er das tut dann andere früher oder
später das gleiche tun darüber haben wir
schon in früheren Videos gesprochen fakt
ist nun mal die Dinge in Russland laufen
nicht besonders gut viele Oligarchen und
lebt her sind sehr unzufrieden mit dem
was durch den Überfall auf die Ukraine
passiert ist in diesem Sinne ist
Hinrichtung eine klare Warnung an alle
Beteiligten wenn du es wachst dich mit
dem Führer anzulegen wirst du die
Konsequenzen tragen
[Musik]
war nicht nur ein Warlord seine Gruppe
war mit vielen verschiedenen Unternehmen
aktiv von der Schokoladenfabrik in St
Petersburg oder einer Wodka Destillerie
bis hin zu Goldminen Kommunikations- und
desinformations-agenturen sowie Öl und
Gasunternehmen in gewisser Weise können
sich viele Oligarchen in ihm
wiederfinden und die Tatsache dass das
Flugzeug abgeschossen wurde ist
vielleicht kein Zufall diese Hinrichtung
sollte nicht nur unübersehbar sein
sondern auch eine klare Botschaft an die
russischen Eliten Eliten die sich
normalerweise in Privatflugzeugen
fortbewegen mit anderen Worten die
Message ist glasklar
wer sich gegen Putin auflehnt kann sich
seines Lebens nie wieder sicher sein und
zwar nirgendwo und ganz gleich Wasser
krabbelt offiziell von sich gibt das
einzige womit errechnen könnt ist seine
Hinterhältigkeit und Unberechenbarkeit
und warum eigentlich hat Putin es gerade
jetzt getan
ist es einfach deswegen passiert weil er
die Gelegenheit dazu hatte nun
vielleicht aber es gibt auch einige
Fakten die die Entscheidung beschleunigt
haben könnten es mag ein Zufall sein
oder auch nicht aber Tatsache ist das in
den Wochen zuvor große Veränderungen bei
Wagner stattgefunden haben die Gruppe
schien sich um zu strukturieren hunderte
von Soldaten verließen Weißrussland
offenbar um sich Wagners Missionen
Afrika anzuschließen einen viel
lukrativeren und im Vergleich zum
ukrainischen Fleischwolf ungleich
sichereren Einsatzort wir reden hier von
vielleicht 1000 bis 1400 Mann das letzte
Video in dem wir pregorian selbst Leben
zu Gesicht bekommen haben wurde ja
ebenfalls in Afrika aufgenommen
das Problem dabei nun wenn Putin Rache
wollte und denk bitte daran dass es
etwas war das er tun musste könnte die
Flucht der Wagner Afrika seine Pläne
verkompliziert haben außerdem könnte die
Gruppe dieses Abenteuer nutzen um sich
zu verstärken und ein größerer Gegner zu
werden ganz zu schweigen davon was ist
für das öffentliche Image Putins
bedeutet wenn Wagner militärische
Erfolge erzielen würde wie hätten der
kleine Mann in seinem Bunker und seine
Bruder gegen ausgesehen
und das bringt uns zum zweiten Grund der
vielleicht erklärt warum beschlossen
wurde dieses Thema ein für alle Mal aus
der Welt zu schaffen schaut euch dieses
Video genau an darin seht ihr die
ukrainische Flagge über der umkämpften
Enklave robotine wählen eine Position um
die seit Juni gekämpft wird und die ist
der ukrainischen Artillerie nun
ermöglicht anzugreifen den nächsten
notwendigen Schritt auf ihrem Vormarsch
den Melitopol ja die ukrainische gegen
Offensive verliebt bisher langsamer als
von vielen ungeduldigen und unkundigen
erwartet aber darüber werden wir bald
hier auf visualpolitik in einem
separaten Video sprechen tatsache ist
jedoch dass die ukrainischen Truppen in
den Tagen vor dem Abschluss des
Flugzeugs einige bemerkenswerte
Fortschritte gemacht haben die auch
Außenstehenden als solche verkauft
werden konnten
so gelang ist der ukrainischen 47
mechanisierten Brigade unterstützt von
der 28 Brigade die Verteidigungslinien
bei Routine zu durchbrechen und den Fall
von roboterne herbeizuführen und diese
Position ermöglicht ist der ukrainischen
Armee nun Operation gegen relativ
schwächere Verteidigungslinien so
starten tatsächlich versuchen nach
Informationen des Institute nun die
Verteidigungsposition zu verstärken die
fast 30 Kilometer von der aktuellen
Front entfernt sind mit anderen Worten
sie befürchten bereits dass die
ukrainischen Truppen ihre Stellungen
überwinden und vorrücken werden
logischerweise stellt dies ein großes
Problem für Putin da und mitbring Ocean
wäre es ein noch größeres gewesen denn
bregorian war ist mit seiner Truppe als
einzigen gelungen das zum mythischen
symbolverkehrte bachmut zu erobern
bachmut war somit auch zu einem Symbol
für die Stärke Wagners und die Schwäche
des regulären russischen Militärs unter
Sergej scholko geworden und bei jedem
ernsthaften Rückschlag in der Ukraine
würde der Kreml als noch größerer
Verlierer da stehen während der Wagen
der Chef sich als Sieger fühlen könnte
außerdem musste das russische Parlament
Ende Juli ein neues Gesetz verabschieden
das den Kreml ermächtigt hunderttausende
weitere Männer in den Krieg zu schicken
dieses Mal wird die Mobilisierung jedoch
ganz anders ablaufen
von nun an kann die Regierung
vertrauliche rekrutierungsaufforderungen
an so viele Männer schicken wie sie für
nötig hält außerdem wurden die
Altersgrenze für die Wehrpflichtigen von
27 auf 30 Jahre angehoben und die
Strafen für die Verweigerung des
Dienstes in der Armee wurden ebenfalls
erhöht und natürlich wird dieser Prozess
egal wie vertraulich oder leise ablaufen
soll nicht populär sein deswegen ist es
besser wenn er auf keine allzu große
Opposition stößt die Puffer für jegliche
Kritik und die Kritiker innerhalb der
russischen Gesellschaft sind aufgezählt
jetzt darf niemand mehr auch nur einen
Millimeter aus der Reihe tanzen umso
mehr als das Putin nicht einmal mehr
diese Propaganda Mission gelungen ist 21
August 2023 die erste russische
mundmission seit 47 Jahren stürzt auf
dem Mond ab und scheitert Russlands
erste Mission seit 47 Jahren war ein
durchschlagender misser Erfolg Russland
verlor die Kontrolle über seinen
Raumschiff und dieses zerschellte auf
der Mond Gespräche während Indien kurz
darauf sein eigenes Raumschiff
problemlos auf dem Mond landen konnte
was für eine Schmach das glorreiche
Russland wurde nun gar vom einstigen
Entwicklungsland Indien überholt und das
auch noch in dem traditionell besonders
prestigeträchtigen Bereich der Raumfahrt
dieser Moment ist unvergesslich er ist
phänomenal es ist der siegesschrei eines
neuen Indiens es stellt sich also die
ernsthafte Frage was bleibt den großen
überhaupt noch worauf sie stolz sein
könnten gibt es noch irgendetwas was
diese Nation irgendwie in positivem
Sinne definieren könnte es ist gut
möglich dass all diese Entwicklungen
eine wichtige Rolle dabei gespielt haben
muss aus Pläne zu beschleunigen sagen
wir einfach das ist von einem Tag auf
den anderen dringlich erschien sich
wenigstens das Problem zu entledigen
wichtig war eben wohl aber auch ihnen
zeitgleich mit und gehen auszuschalten
um uns noch mal in Erinnerung zu rufen
und will es sich hier gehandelt hat der
bekennende Neonazi und ehemalige
Offizier des russischen Geheimdienstes
war der ursprüngliche Gründer der
wagnersöllnertruppe diese
beziehungsweise ihre
Vorgängerorganisation das slavonische
Chor befand sich nach ihrer Gründung
2013 aber im Clinch mit Putins Geheimnis
FSB aber der Kreml vertraute sorgte
damals für die richtigen Kontakte nach
oben die nötige Finanzierung und gab und
kindskillern den passenden
geschäftlichen Rahmen und seitdem
ergänzen sich die beiden wo immer es nur
ging auch während der Meuterei war es
gut gehen gewesen der die Kolonne auf
Moskau anführte während das Geschehen
damals von Rostock am Donner
auskommandierte während
dann zwar zahlreiche wagnere anwesend
darunter der von Putin als neuer Wagner
favorisierte André Chef der sich
übrigens nicht unter den Opfern des
Abschlusses befand und gehen weidoch
wohl nicht zusammen mitmachen Moskau
gereist das du agierte äußerst
vorsichtig damit im Falle des Todes oder
der Festung des einen Wagner noch
handlungsfähig wäre doch diese
überlebenswichtige Paranoia scheint bei
Goschen und Menschen im Laufe der
vergangenen zwei Monate im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes verflogen zu sein und
auf diese Weise bot sich Putin endlich
die Gelegenheit das meutereipotenzial
Wagners im Falle einer Liquidierung
Brick Oceans zu minimieren indem man
pregorian noch zwei weitere Monate frei
gewähren ließ bot sich dem FSB natürlich
auch die Möglichkeit in Erfahrung zu
bringen mit wem er in Verbindung war auf
diese Weise konnte die Säuberung dann
gründlicher durchgeführt werden außerdem
wollte sich Putin vor einer Liquidierung
wohl auch dahin geht absichern dass ihre
Auswirkungen auf seine Afrika Politik
nicht zu drastisch ausfallen nur einen
Tag vor dem Crash verkündete er nämlich
dass der Kreml sein Engagement auf dem
Kontinent verstärken würde ein Hinweis
darauf dass er einen Weg gefunden hat
zumindest Teile der afrikanischen Vagina
Aktivitäten zu übernehmen aber es zeigt
auch wie unvorbereitet Putin wohl noch
vor zwei Monaten war als gregorien auf
begehrte die letzte Frage die
beantworten müssen lautet jedoch was
genau sind die Folgen dieses Anschlags
welche Bedeutung wird diese Hinrichtung
haben und passt jetzt auf passt sehr gut
aus
wie folgen
liebe Freunde wir können zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt vier direkte Folgen
identifizieren die mit dem Ableben
pregorians bereits feststehen kurz und
mittelfristig scheint es klar dass Putin
gestärkt daraus hervorgeht er befand
sich in der Defensive Schienen wirklich
in allen Belangen auf der
Verliererstraße unterwegs zu sein und
plötzlich bum ein großer
Befreiungsschlag der Kreml scheint seine
Risse zu schließen andererseits wird die
Hinrichtung so wie sie durchgeführt
wurde die allgemeine Paranoia verstärken
und das könnte sich für den Kreml zu
einem immer größeren Problem auswachsen
wenn die informationsblase in der
Wladimir Putin lebt bisher überschaubar
war könnte sie jetzt noch verstärkt
werden für einen rücksichtslosen
autokarten zu arbeiten liegt nicht
gerade dazu ein riesigen einzugehen und
ohne Risiken gibt es auch keine Chancen
ganz im Gegenteil keiner mehr wird
bereits seit Verantwortung zu übernehmen
oder gar auf Fehler hinzuweisen wenn
Putin 2021 und 22 überzeugt davon war
dass die Ukraine in zwei oder drei Tagen
fallen würde könnte es jetzt noch
schlimmer werden wenn zum Beispiel
bereits bekannt war dass die Leute in
Putins in ihrem Kreis und die russische
Elite ihre Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
erhöhen könnten Sie dies nun auf die
Spitze treiben
niemand in Russland ist mehr sicher
andererseits bedeutet der Sturz
pregorians auch das Ende der für Putin
bisher sehr nützlichen wagnergruppe es
ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass ihre
Geschäfte unter verschiedenen Oligarchen
aufgeteilt oder direkt von der
russischen Regierung übernommen werden
dies bedeutet jedoch nicht nur den
faktischen Verlust einer wichtigen und
vor allem funktionierenden militärischen
Struktur nein Russland wird
höchstwahrscheinlich auch viel Einfluss
in Afrika verlieren und natürlich seinen
Joker gegen die Ukraine
und schließlich dürfte auch dem
allerletzten Hinterwäldler geworden sein
das ist keinerlei Sinn macht mit Putin
zu verhandeln dabei spielt es keine
Rolle ob es um pregorian Frieden für die
Ukraine Rohstoffe Getreidelieferungen
oder ein anderes Thema geht der Mafioso
im Kreml hält selten sein Wort und
selbst genugen Ehre bedeutet ihm nichts
allen beschwichtigern und
verhandlungsforder daran die sich so
gern als Freunde des Friedens betiteln
sind nun wirklich die allerletzten
Argumente verloren gegangen ihre apismen
Sucht irgendwie zu rechtfertigen viele
westliche Akteure haben in der
Diskussion über die Hilfe für die
Ukraine selbst auferlegte
Einschränkungen akzeptiert wodurch die
militärische Hilfe für die Ukraine
künstlich begrenzt wurde ihre
Befürchtung war stets das jegliche Hilfe
als eskalierend von Putin angesehen
werden und so extrem Reaktionen führen
könnte doch jedes Mal wenn solche roten
Linien überschritten wurden passierte
nichts durch diese selbstauferlegte
Zurückhaltung wurde der Krieg nur
verlängert und blutiger gemacht und die
Annahme dass es schlimm sein könnte wenn
Putin fällt weil er durch jemand noch
Schlimmeres ersetzt werden könnte ist wo
die absurdeste dieser selbst auferlegten
Ideen sie führt ironischerweise dazu
Putins Macht zu legitimieren und
impliziert das Putins macht verbleibt
irgendwie gut sein was er jedoch
überhaupt nicht ist die hinterhältige
Hinrichtung pregorian soll diese bizarre
Debatte hoffentlich einfach alle mal
beenden nein putin ist nicht das
geringere Übel weil da jemand noch
schlimmeres wie z.B bring Goschen an die
Macht kommen könnte es wäre schon eine
ziemlich große Herausforderung schlimmer
und Böse als Putin zu sein er hat diesen
verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg mit all
seinen goldtaten gewollt und losgetreten
und er ist ist der ihn bis zum bitteren
Ende weiterführen will wir haben es mit
einem blutrünstigen expansionistischen
Diktator zu tun der regelmäßig seine
genozidale Ideologie propagiert und
bereit ist hunderttausende und wenn
nötig Millionen abzuschlachten um seine
Ziele durchzusetzen diese Krieg war
seine Entscheidung ohne Putin hätte er
nicht stattfinden müssen in der Tat sind
große Teile der russischen
entsetzt die hinricht entfernt einen
Spieler den einige für schlimmer als
Putin hielten Prägung fehlte letzten
Endes jedoch Putins kaltblütige
Rücksichtslosigkeit ergab sich Putin hin
sollte Putin jedoch ersetzt werden würde
sein Nachfolger Zeit benötigen um seine
Macht zu konsolidieren was der Ukraine
Vorteile bringen könnte es ist daher
unwahrscheinlich dass selbst ein
schlimmerer Nachfolger den Krieg
ausweiten würde mit den Informationen
die wir zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung
dieses Videos haben scheint Putin durch
den Tod brings also wieder fester im
Sattel zu sitzen aber Vorsicht er hat
immer noch einen Krieg am Hals wachsende
und Zufriedenheit unter dem Militärs und
eine unschöne Situation im eigenen Land
da bring Goschen nicht nur bei dem
sollten sondern auch bei weiten Teilen
des Militärs hoch angesehen waren dürfte
ihre Beseitigung zu weiterer
Demoralisierung und Verbitterung führen
Putin hat der Ukraine einen großen
Gefallen erwiesen in den er diese zwei
hochgradig gefährlichsten die
kompetenten Feinde Kiews beseitigte sie
waren zu unkonventionellen Ansätzen und
Lösungen in komplexen Situationen fähig
etwas wo später er noch scheuge oder
gerassimov in der Lage sind ebenfalls
eins pottchen Lachen dürfte sich
Frankreich dem Wagner in Afrika immer
mehr Kopfzerbrechen bereitet hat denn
inwieweit die nun herrenlos gewordenen
Söldner einen scheuge oder irgendeinen
anderen Putin Amigo als Führungsfigur
akzeptieren werden steht in den Sternen
hat mal wieder Kompetenz gegen Loyalität
getauscht das mal kurzfristig ein kluger
Schachzug gewesen sein wird aber nicht
ewig funktionieren der Diktator laut
sein Land und das System immer weiter
aus die Puffer schmelzen zusammen und
die Zahl der Optionen auch dies gilt
sowohl in militärischer politischer
diplomatischer als auch wirtschaftlicher
Hinsicht und deswegen werden wir über
jeden dieser Bereiche schon bald
separate Videos veröffentlichen vergisst
also bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen
um sich zu verpassen und unterstützt
bitte auch unsere Projekt mit einer
Spende über den Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung natürlich interessiert
uns auch eure Meinung zu diesem Thema
wie bewertet ihr den stoßzins und glaubt
ihr dass er Putin Positionen in Russland
für lange Zeit festigt was denkt ihr was
die nächsten Schritte des Krems sein
werden und könnte sich vielleicht eine
Gruppe loyale Anhänger brigochiens und
Ort kennenzulernen wahrer Ganoven Ehre
daran versuchen Blutrache an Putin
scheuge und gerissen aufzuüben weil sie
ihre Paten umbringen ließen also haut in
die Tasten und hinterlasst uns eure
Eindrücke im Kommentarbereich falls euch
diese Video gefallen hat gebt ihm bitte
auch ein Like und teils mit euren
Freunden um es mit ihnen zu diskutieren
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]